في سيفر 1 انجليزي نحن ناخذ سلامه الجميع
بريطانيا على محمل الجد وهذا على وجه
الخصوص يشمل الصحفيين الذين يكشفون اساليب
معامله حكوميتهم لشعبهم نحن نتابع هذه
التظاهرات العفويه للنساء الايرانيات ذوات
يقولون من خلالها لنظام في طهران لقد
اكتفينا من سوء معاملته لهم والصحفيون
الذين يوفقون تلك التظاهرات يجب ان يحصلوا
على الحمايه وفي بريطانيا سنوفر لهم
الحمايه
غريب بعض الشيء ان تكون هذه التهديدات على
الاراضي البريطانيه انا اقطن في بريطانيا
هي بلد امن جدا لماذا تتجرا ايران على هذه
التهديدات ضد بريطانيا
من الحكومه الايرانيه ونظام في طهران هو
رغبتهما في القاء اللوم على دول اخرى بسبب
اتبعات الناجمه السوري معاملتهم للشعب
الايراني النساء في ايران اللواتي يقفنا
في وجه سوء العاملته يتظاهرن ضد الحكومه
يقومن بذلك لانهن اكتفينا من الحكومه
الايرانيه وبدلا من معالجته همومهن
والاصغاء اليهم ايران وتحاول التنصل من
سلوكياتها واللقاء اليوم على دول اخرى من
ضمنها بريطانيا غير ان كل ما يجري الان هو
نتيجه لسلوكيات الحكومه الايرانيه ونحن
بدورنا سنضمن المحافظه على امن الشعب
البريطاني وكل من يعيش ويعمل في المملكه
المتحده وسنصلت الضوء على شجاعه المراه
الايرانيه التي وقفت وعبرت بصوتها وطالبت
بالتغيير ايران